did you go to the park or anything i did
yeah we went to a park
um we tried to and then
for some reason like ollie got super
anxious about
uh uh i was just like i think he was
like over
overly stimulated because the weirdly
the park was cracking on a wednesday
was it it was kind of popping for a
wednesday i was like okay
this is this is where this is where it
happens now and what ollie was freaking
out
he wasn't like freaking out like he just
wouldn't sit still we try to you know we
try to just
have a little picnic it's not the worst
yeah like just lay the [ __ ] down
yeah no rel it's for our all of our own
goods just relax
yeah you know and he was bugging out and
he just kept trying to run away
and there was something about the spot
we were at that he just didn't like and
then we tried to move into another spot
and he's
he started his attention was just going
crazy
so we said [ __ ] it and and we we went to
another park where he finally calmed
down
triple park double double it was double
park
double park okay yeah yeah yeah oh you
moved to another spot
in the first park right right right yeah
oh and then you park hopped yeah then we
park hopped yeah
that's what partying is now with with
coronavirus so everyone's just park
hopping
dude and all the parks got like all most
most parks were like memorials to people
which is
[ __ ] hilarious yeah dude uh pull up
to richard b hopkins sports park
we're by the swing set it's closed so
just turn up dude
big park vibes seriously pull up it's
[ __ ]
dumb litty at this memorial park
richard b hopkins
yo come through to the um to the um
uh uh to the sky beach gated community
just hopped the fence in the back
we're at children's park number two no
one no one's even here dude it's so
chill
just take the exit for the uh janet
lamina
cemetery we're right beside the cemetery
pull up dude
we're playing spike ball too we're
playing for you
you see people playing spike ball no
we're not
what the [ __ ] is nobody no i'm not there
not there no
it was it was more like um it was
the vibe was kind of more like um you
know
everyone was like kind of huddled over
their food and he's like looking around
and they're like
is anybody else [ __ ] up here is it
cool if i'd
just is it cool if we crack this
fourth bottle of rose
you know people are [ __ ] up because
when they leave and they take they put
their bag over the shoulder it's like
cling cling cling
cling tingling seven wine bottles and
they're banging against each other
that's somebody's mom somebody's mom
throwing that [ __ ] over her [ __ ]
don't that sit over her shoulder looking
like a pirate with all these empty
bottles and one eye open just [ __ ]
walking like she has a peg leg because
she's so [ __ ] up just
bottles for sale
y'all never be as [ __ ] up as me
[Music]
i'm so [ __ ] up i got scurvy
dude is your mom all right yeah dude
she's just in peg leg mode it's always
[ __ ] up when she goes to peg-leg mode
[Laughter]
oh my god that's so funny dude i'm
getting so [ __ ] up tonight
i'm gonna be captain jack sparrow
just so flirting with people's
girlfriends and
disappearing abruptly
no just putting on eyeliner okay yeah
that's it let me get so [ __ ] up i'm
gonna put on eyeliner
and come out randomly sick man you look
like chris
angel that's [ __ ] tight no dude
you're dressed like
super [ __ ] corporate just like biz
cash but you just put on the eyeliner
and act like nothing happened
what's good oh did did your girlfriend
oh no no i did that just real quick
so yeah why
i don't know man it's just a you know
kind of in the mood
get crazy yeah company get together
why why not
do we do i say this my rockstar persona
kind of comes out
we need to i'm telling you man it'd be
so funny if we went
somewhere and got accepted for a
corporate gig
like nobody knew who we were which is
easy
and we just we work there for like a
week and we do this [ __ ]
and we make we make our own reality tv
show out of it
just go to a meeting with eyeliner on
all right we want to introduce our uh uh
two new recruits on our dev team
uh cody and noelle let me just look up
from the hey what's up oh
what's good what's happening
oh you got a little yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's our thing
it'd be funny to like go full goth but
not the
main outfit like have the blue
just the face in here yeah the khakis
and then you're wearing like fishnet
it's on your arms
[Laughter]
an eyeliner and like a lip piercing
what's good hey
i'm sorry i can't take you oh what what
my my expression is is weird to you
this is how i express no anyway um
i'm still thinking about pirate mom
i never [ __ ] my husband no matter how
drunk i is
her husband in the corner like yeah
here she goes again yeah mom give me
your keys
i am the captain of this ship give me
your [ __ ] keys mom
hell yeah the dad
the dad just yeah it's true it won't
even let me hit the poop deck
nope no poop deck always off limits
been been a dream of mine for years but
never gonna happen yep
even now never fellas let me tell you
something
just drunk talking to those kids friends
find you a woman who lets you go on the
poop deck
okay okay
who lets you clean the poop deck okay
anything on the poop deck because i
don't
ugh oh god forbid i asked her to walk
the plank
oh god here we go
here we go she hasn't walked my plank in
years
is what would could walking the plane
could be like a nice
you know covert name for uh getting a
foot job
i think it means that she's literally
walking on his boner okay
yeah just like a cirque du soleil act or
is it is it more aggressive
like she's stomping his dick nothing
let's not bring back
all right how much do you get not your
balls your dick stomped
am i hard or not
[Laughter]
200 bucks
[Laughter]
wow that took no convincing
straight straight away yeah go ahead
yeah um 200 bucks yeah
i mean could that be a nice little
covert hey you want
want to walk the plank tonight yeah i'm
totally down
yeah i think that means foot job
probably it could it could mean a foot
job
yeah anyway yeah sorry par yeah okay but
the park made me want to turn up at a
park
like that's what i'm saying yeah